yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
the super popular Angry Birds game has
been catapulted onto the big screen to
give us the Angry Birds movie queue 97
minutes of bright and breezy colors zany
action and bristly pace comedy which
will doubtless keep kids entertained
while providing enough jokes aimed at
adults in the audience to keep grown-ups
happy to the crazy and somewhat slight
story revolves around the avian paradise
of bird island where all the birds are
happy except from red who gets pretty
annoyed about everything including the
arrival of a bunch of green pigs to the
island now you don't need to have played
the game before to understand what's
going on or to enjoy the movie as you
probably expect though whether you're an
angry birds addict or a total newcomer
there's a stack of bird and pig related
puns throughout the film one-liners
sight gags slapstick and some gross out
here a fly by thick and fast some of the
jokes hitting some not it's also a quite
a number of rather fun Easter eggs and
pop-culture references and I'll have a
video on that coming soon I'll add the
link here so you can click there to see
it when it's ready the movies voice cast
contains a wealth of familiar faces
hidden behind their animated avian and
swine ish characters Jason Sudeikis
Danny McBride and Josh GAD are
entertaining a feathered friends red Bob
and Chuck who meets at an
anger-management class run by Matilda
who's voiced by bridesmaids star Maya
Rudolph Sean Penn gets to grunt his way
through the movie as the intimidatingly
gruff Terrence inside outs Bill Hader
plays the pigs wickedly cunning leader
Leonard with real Glee while Game of
Thrones star Peter Dinklage has an
amusing role of the once heroic mighty
eagle in fact the voice cast is littered
with well-known names from comedy
including keegan-michael key Ike
Barinholtz from the Mindy project beeps
Tony Hale SNL's Kate McKinnon titus
Burgess from unbreakable kimmy schmitt
and lots more it's just a shame that
many of their roles are so small and
that the film flies by so phonetically
that a number of them don't get to
really register or make a real impact
first-time directors fergal reilly and
clay haters in their team of animators
have done a great job creating
incredibly appealing colorful characters
while the Angry Birds movie doesn't
quite hit the animated heights of the
best of Pixar or Disney or the lego
movie say it's still a good deal of fun
so to sum up the Angry Birds movie is
lie
entertaining and bursting at the seams
with quality voice cast anarchic
attitude and a barrage of jokes while
it's not the animated equivalent of a
gourmet meal to be lingered over it's
certainly a tasty fast-food treat the
Angry Birds movie gets 3 out of 5 flicks
now what did you think of the Angry
Birds movie and if you played the Angry
Birds game did you like the way they
adapt it for the big screen
let me know in the comments below if you
liked this review I'd love it if you'd
share it and do subscribe for more movie
reviews Easter egg videos and amazing
movie facts click the links here to
check those out thanks for watching and
see you next time you be gay movie
lovers